the stock market is not the economy many
people
own no stocks at all many people own
very little but the stock market is
one indicator that we look at and the
stock market
has collapsed this week as coronavirus
continues to explode and ravage the
country
and as donald trump still has no plan
nor even any interest in dealing with
the virus
at this point either we keep falling
more and more
into a dystopian nightmare with the
pandemic or donald trump gets replaced
it's one of the two
trump is not going to fix this all right
but the stock market is
absolutely imploding the first three
days this week the dow
closing last week at roughly 28 300
monday down 600 points tuesday down
another couple hundred points
yesterday falling off a cliff down
nearly a thousand points the decline for
these first three days of the week
about 1700 points now the specifics of
the impact of the stock market being
down
are heavily concentrated among companies
and rich people who own the vast
majority of stock that is very true
but this is a signal about the
confidence in the american economy
and because of the virus confidence is
very low we are seeing
record coronavirus numbers we have a
third
spike already reaching and surpassing
the single day
case highs of late july we've had over
80 000 cases multiple days over the last
few weeks of over the last week rather
and even though trump said we would not
see more deaths
the seven day average of deaths in the
united states
has been starting to climb since the
middle of october remember
deaths used to lag cases by two to three
weeks
now that we're better at treating the
virus death slag cases by a little bit
more
even people who die are staying alive a
little bit longer as
as sort of morose as that is and
hospitalizations
are peaking again and potentially on
their way
to the highest peak we've seen thus far
if and when the hospitals get
full you will see the death rate grow up
dramatic go up dramatically and we still
have no plan
the stock market is rattled because
there is still no plan
trump bemoaning that the media is
talking about the pandemic
saying at his rallies and tweeting many
times some version of this tweet from
yesterday where he said quote
covidkovitkovid is the unified chant of
the fake
news lamestream media they will talk
about nothing else until november 4th
when the election will be hopefully over
then they talk then then the talk will
be how low the death rate is
plenty of hospital rooms and many tests
of young people
he's living in a fantasy world and we
knew
they were going to go with the idea of
let people get used to a thousand deaths
a day
let it become normal and while that
is completely immoral it actually might
have worked
were it only for the deaths but this is
a real economics lesson which
anthony scaramucci pointed out on
twitter anthony scaramucci former guest
on this program check out that interview
former white house coms director
scaramucci tweeted economics lesson for
the soon-to-be
ex-president the virus needed to be
contained
to help the economy and stock markets
federal stimulus would never be enough
you crushed the stock market and the
economy by not understanding this
trump thought for political gain i will
ignore it
the problem is the economy and the stock
market won't ignore it
and they will notice that even if they
don't care or agree to ignore
the deaths they are having a massive
impact on the economy and as europe is
in its second spike we're already in our
third
and it is getting very ugly we need a
plan we need someone to take control of
the pandemic trump can't do it
he's also not trying they've given up
remember over the last
weekend trump's deranged masculis
chief of staff mark meadows actually
said
we're not going to control the pandemic
check this out from cnn
so here's what we have to do we're not
going to control the pandemic we are
going to control the fact that we
get uh vaccines therapeutics and other
mitigations why are we going to get
arrows
because it is a contagious virus just
like the fully but why not make efforts
to contain it
well we are making efforts to contain it
by running all over the country not
wearing a mask
that's what the vice president back and
forth let me just say this
is what we need to do is make sure that
we have
the proper mitigation factors whether
it's therapies or vaccines or treatments
they've given up that's it what we have
ahead of us
maybe if we replace donald trump with
joe biden
is that joe biden will take the pandemic
seriously and in general
american stock markets and economies do
better under democratic presidents
that's a historical reality and that's
also what we're counting on at this
point
but we have to make it happen otherwise
this
this is horrible this may only be the
beginning
if we don't remove donald trump let me
know your thoughts and reaction
i'm on twitter deepakman if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my
all-time favorite apps called blinkist
blinkist lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video